that whole chunk of material you do in
the Netflix special about you know your
wife and the fact that like you're
having babies and for some reason you
guys never end up in a hospital we
almost have our first kid in Newberg and
despite that our second baby was born in
the lobby of our department she had a
baby in the lobby of our building I mean
that is unbelievable I love I love when
you talk about how like now the doorman
in your building you can't even look at
them yeah like one of the doormen saw
her vagina and that feeling you
described in the special of being
useless in earth of your child I mean
the doorman was more useful you know
everybody it was really this nice
collective moment that's a sort of
uniquely New York or any building where
a lot of people are living I just
remember the labor on all three of my
girls were like was this long drawn-out
thing in the hospital walking up and
down the hallways yeah this is like an
prizes like when is this kid coming
already the water broke six days ago
right
your wife's like boom well I mean this
is of course the secret is that
ultimately given a choice she'd rather
have it quickly in the lobby right then
30 hours in a hospital I you're right
get it out right let's go I mean thank
God it was our second one but who like
you describe your wife in the special as
like how do you put it you say she she
Lion King to me like it was like Lion
King get held up like crazy but I'm
really into the logistics of this thing
in other words you're standing there yes
you don't know what to do oh honey this
is beautiful yeah I can see the head
coming up and the door like a
play-by-play right how do you do it
and then like so no one is pulling the
baby out right we had a UH we had to do
it with us so she was just card sort of
calming Alexi down but you know it is um
I'm and what I mean by like thank God it
was a second when I watched the first
one get born in a hospital right when
you watch it you think to yourself this
is something has gone terribly wrong
right even though that's how it always
looks
right and you only know it's normal
because the doctors aren't freaking out
that's right but so the second one again
it looked as bad as the first one like
it's not
think about it looks like it should be
happening and who cleans up if they did
the doormen have to clean with the
placenta and all that don't care this is
you want to know what an Alfa my wife is
this true story
let me hear this so might we on the way
to the hospital because you still then
have to get in the ambulance so now the
baby's born you know we had a fireman
cut the umbilical cord really a fireman
cut the milk he knew how to do that yeah
he had he just said the stander back
crazy um but then we get it and my wife
uh says to me hey write the head of the
co-op board and say we'll pay for a new
carpet but not because she felt bad
because she wanted to pick the carpet
right she thought like oh this way I'll
it'll give me a chance to put my own
personal touch that's smart
yeah she really isn't alpha she liked
the fact that on the way to the hospital
she would think like oh I'm and I have a
way to get this to pay off for me
you